back in November Xbox one owners got
access to more than 100 xbox 360 games
through the new xbox one backwards
compatibility feature Xbox is Major
Nelson has announced that as of today
December 17th you can get 16 more the
latest list contains triple-a
blockbusters such as fable 3 and Halo
Reach plus a few indie titles such as
braid and splosion man check out
gamespot to see the full list Major
Nelson also mentions that the Xbox team
plans to add more games to the catalog
on a regular basis so if your favorite
360 game isn't on the list right now
there's still hope in the meantime you
can visit xbox uservoice calm to vote
for the games you want to see make the
leap since backwards compatibility
launched xbox one owners have logged
over 9 million hours playing previous
generation games most popular games
include Assassin's Creed to fallout 3
and gears of war two whenever Microsoft
surprises us with its next batch of
backward compatible 360 games you can
read all about it on gamespot com this
is Tony logging out